[Musik]
heute mache ich mich mal schick ich war
ja schon oft im Bundestag aber an einem
so historischen Datum boah Freunde ich
habe Gänsehaut
ja wir feiern heute die Ampel hat es
geschafft und beschließt gemeint mein
Gesetz ist ja absurd gemeinsam mit der
FDP
selber nicht glauben ich kann selber
nicht glauben ja was ist schon sehr
schade eigentlich das ist nach außen
sehr negativ natürlich diskutiert worden
das hätte nicht sein müssen aber es
freut mich sehr dass wir das bekommen
haben was wir wollen
aber wieder sagen müssen dass die Kamera
läuft
werden Sie den Tag heute feiern im
Kreise der Koalition oder doch mit
Freunden ich werde heute abend meine
Kinder was schönes kochen also doch mit
Freunden und Familie ja schönen Tag
Ihnen auch können Sie sich noch an den
Tag erinnern wo sie waren als das
heizungsgesetz verabschiedet wurde
reicht nicht gut erinnern kann wo ich
heute war ja in Deutschland bei ihnen
hat sich der Tag eingebrannt ja nicht
vergessen herr Scholz ich finde es schon
mal mit jemandem zu sprechen der mit dem
heizungsgesetz gar nichts zu tun hatte
ich habe sogar mitverhandelt an dem an
dem heizungsgesetz die SPD war dabei
tatsächlich ja ich habe inhaltlich
beteiligt ich habe nur grün und FDP
auseinandergehalten ich habe eine 50
Cent Deckel für Mieterinnen und Mieter
in Deutschland raus gehandelt mehr als
50 Cent dürfen die pro Quadratmeter beim
heizungswechsel künftig nicht zahlen war
die SPD redet halt in der heute schon
immer keiner drüber aber das müssen wir
rausschneiden ja
es funktioniert genau beim Heizungs
ungsgesetz wurde die Ausnahme Regel für
über 80-jährige jetzt doch wieder
gestrichen da machen sich viele
Betroffene natürlich Sorgen ja alles
fast wie immer im Alters wird zum Start
aber dafür der KÖSTER heute mal gut
angezogen also hat sie richtig Mühe
gegeben Option Witze machen aber ich
will nicht nur mit den üblichen
Verdächtigen reden sondern auch mit
denen die immer vor mir weglaufen zum
Glück habe ich auf der
Journalistenschule perfide Interview
Techniken
wenn sie das heizungsgesetz auch in
Desaster finden dann gehen Sie jetzt
einfach weiter
[Gelächter]
Fragen beantworten nee ich gehe jetzt
einfach weiter niemand versteht es mehr
es gibt nur Ausnahmen da drin Ölheizung
dürfen noch verbaut werden sogar
Holzpellets
sinnvoll wenn ich mir zum Beispiel
Bayern anschauen dass die dort auch
weiterhin die Wälder die sie haben
nutzen können wenn der Dorfe das wäre
Ferne nutzen auch nicht ganz
klimaneutral das stimmt aber wir gehen
zum großen Schritt mit dem Gesetz und
manchmal muss man ersten Schritt gehen
und das ist meine Überleitung
[Musik]
finden Sie das heizungsgesetz so jetzt
ist es gut ja fand ich wirklich also auf
Handwerker gesagt im kacke aber jetzt
ist es gut und wir haben es jetzt
richtig auf dem Weg gebracht und jetzt
nehmen wir die Bürger jetzt so viele
Ausnahmen drin sind dass ich eigentlich
gar nichts mehr ändern
nach außen zeigen wir das negativ aber
intern lieben wir uns eigentlich es ist
eine gezwungene Hochzeit gewesen aber
dennoch wir mögen uns
solange sie die FDP sind
die Interviews mit ihnen weil die sind
so erfrischend ehrlich das stimmt ja man
kann ja jetzt schon sagen dass das neue
heizungsgesetz die Wirtschaft ankurbelt
im ersten Halbjahr 23 wurden mehr
Ölheizung verkauft
geil danke Ampel nein
ja ist das geil
zurück ins Studio
[Applaus]
ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile fast alle
versteckten Symbole hier bei uns im
neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer staatsfon ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben
es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf Youtube
boah also ich würde mich ranhalten